good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock we are live from Wigan my
hometown on the breakfast show here on
Sky news this morning day three of our
week of special coverage looking at the
cost of living crisis and how it's
impacting on these good people of Wigan
on a day when the latest inflation data
could reach a 40-year high we'll bring
you those numbers very shortly with
Helena and also reactions throughout the
morning as well with Ali today we're at
The Brick which is a community project
helping people facing crisis and poverty
we'll be joined by the people who are
working here and many others doing their
bit to help make life a little bit
easier for locals here in my hometown
battling to make ends meet I'll also
speak to the foreign secretary Liz trust
shortly plus the shadow Chancellor and
that is Rachel Reeves what day is it
it's Wednesday the 18th of May the
chancellor is under pressure to take
action as the cost of living continues
to rise the latest inflation figures out
in just a second
as bills go up we speak to a small
business owner weighed down by Soaring
costs
why else can I do
there's nothing you can do when your
food bills are just climbing and
climbing and climbing and your house
bills are climate and climbing and
climbing how much more can you call back
as inflation soars the impact is felt
everywhere we're live in the market to
speak to concerned customers and travel
Traders
hey don't make jigsaw Eccles cakes off
things do stick on walls but night and
day they work away at Uncle George men
fall scars
we find out how one of wigan's most
iconic businesses is recovering
post-pandemic and why it's so important
to this tank
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and the locals are using their vocals to
their musical talent to raise funds for
charity a special live performance just
before the end of the show
also coming up on the program for you
this morning wherever you're watching us
right around the world
I'm live outside New Scotland Yard as a
conservative MP is arrested on suspicion
of rape and sexual assaults over a seven
year period
how many Ukraine where President
zelenski says they are working to get
the remaining Fighters out of the as of
stall steelworks while the fate of those
who've been evacuated already remains
uncertain
foreign
everybody live from Wigan this morning
day three the UK is in the midst of a
cost of living crisis and it's set to
get even worse with inflation numbers
out this morning with the chancellor
facing ever growing pressure to
intervene more on that in just a second
this week I'm in my hometown to find out
how people here are being affected by
Soaring prices morning everybody good
morning good morning good morning they
were noisier than this earlier trust me
in the past few months there's been a
huge increase in the number of people
coming through these doors looking for
support we'll have a walk around we'll
tell you what they do here we'll tell
you about the people that come here
we'll tell you how they're helping we'll
tell you how they need more volunteers
but first the inflation figures Helen
Ann's here hi Helen and tell me morning
Kate so these are sort of the numbers
the statistics putting a figure on just
how bad things are what you've been
covering all week here in Wigan and
unfortunately it is really quite bad in
the 12 months to April inflation Rose by
nine percent uh so nine percent
inflation to put that in some context we
just need to take a step back and just
appreciate just how big that is just how
historic it is the last time inflation
was that high was 40 years ago in 1982
and remember coming into the early 80s I
was off that back of the Big Oil crisis
huge inflation in the 70s so many lost
jobs it really changed the way that
Central bankers and governments thought
about inflation that's how serious and
big these numbers are a few drivers
particularly these in the month of April
remember that was the month that the
off-gen price cap went up so energy
figures a massive massive contributor to
that a few other things going on vat
went up in the month of April 2 which uh
back up to what it had been pre-pandemic
so a few things going on but I think for
families at home for people in Wigan
that you'll be talking to today okay
it's a number that really backs up what
they're feeling in their lives isn't it
that the cost of living is extortionate
and it really is a crisis that we're
living in a figure nine percent nine
percent in the 12 months to April okay
thank you Helen and joining us now is
the foreign secretary Liz trasmus trust
thanks for joining us on the program
this morning we're heading towards a
recession aren't we
we are in a very very difficult economic
situation we're facing some very very
serious Global headwinds and you know as
you've said inflation is extremely high
what we're doing is working to increase
growth in our economy attract investment
to the United Kingdom to face down these
Global headwinds but there's no doubt it
is very difficult for people across
Britain and in fact across the world
what exactly tell me what exactly is the
downside to a win full tax why don't we
do that at least in the short term
well I've just talked about how we need
to attract investment one of the
successes we've had is the very high
number of people in work we've got the
lowest unemployment since 1974 and the
reason we've been able to do that is
because Britain has been attracting
investment attracting new businesses to
come up and set up in the United Kingdom
and the problem with the windfall tax is
it makes it difficult to attract future
investment into our country so there is
a cost in imposing attacks like that and
my view is lower taxes are the best way
to attract more investment to get the
businesses into this country that can
create these high paid jobs which is
what we need to face down these Global
headwinds and I I travel in a lot a lot
in my job as foreign secretary I've seen
very very high inflation elsewhere too
and the reason is we're coming out of
the covid crisis there really is a
problem with Supply chains we've got the
appalling war that Russia has started in
Ukraine which is affecting food prices
that's affecting oil and gas prices and
we're seeing those global headwinds in
the United Kingdom what we need to do is
make sure we're attracting the
investment we're attracting the
businesses to be able to create those
future jobs they're going to help us
deal with this very difficult situation
yeah but that argument immediately
starts to unravel when you hear from the
head of BP the CEO Bernard Looney who
they made 6.2 billion dollars 6.2
billion dollars profit in the first
quarter of this year and they say don't
care whether you give us a windfall tax
or not it's not going to impact on the
investment that we are going to make in
the UK so as far as these oil Giants are
concerned a one-off windfall tax will
help the people of Wigan here bringing
down the cost that they are having to
Shell out every single month and it
could be the difference between them
eating and heating he says it's okay to
do it so why don't the government just
do it well what I want to see is
businesses like that investing in new
infrastructure in the United Kingdom we
need those high quality jobs we need
success in the future so what those
businesses who have made profits during
the last few years need to be doing is
unlocking their balance sheets and
investing in the United Kingdom that's
the way we're going to get the
sustainable future that we all want
but but he says that he is going to do
that anyway
well then he can do even more if he's
got more uh profits that have been
raised during during this period
so you're suggesting that BP should
invest even more money in the UK than
they are already I I absolutely am and
we know we've got a massive issue with
energy you know we need more green
energy we need more nuclear energy in
the United Kingdom what I want to see
energy companies doing is investing in
those facilities so the next time we
have an oil and gas price spike which is
one of the major causes of this issue
we're seeing that investment in new
energy so it's easier for us to
withstand it and keep prices low for
consumers
okay so you're content you'd rather have
a a recession a short-term recession
hopefully then get these big oil Giants
to pay a windfall taxes is that what
you're saying in Bleak terms
nobody can predict whether or not there
will be a a you know economic problems
the best thing the government can do is
attract the investment keep people in
work we're doing what we can to help
households I know the chancellor is
looking at further measures that we can
take of course we completely understand
it's a very difficult situation for
people across the country including in
Wigan we are facing these Global
headwinds and we need to deal with them
by attracting the investment into the
United Kingdom making sure that we have
those high quality jobs of course we're
very very concerned about the
circumstances people are facing that's
why we've created things like the
household support fund to help people
get through these difficult times but
ultimately our country's long-term
future is dependent on creating those
high-paid jobs getting that investment
into Britain
so how many hours a week should people
have to work in order not to be poor
it's up to people how many hours they
work how many hours they work a week I
mean this is what we are doing is making
sure that all households are supported
through our household support fund it's
not about how many hours people are
working it's about making sure there are
enough of those high paid jobs in the
future and you know we're creating at
present lowest unemployment as I've said
since 1974 so that we can weather this
very very difficult storm
your home office ministers tell me just
on Monday that people should work more
hours than they won't be poor
I think that's a mischaracterization of
what she said Kay we know that it's very
very difficult times for people across
the United Kingdom we know that we are
facing higher costs this is a global
phenomenon there's High inflation across
the world because of the energy price
spike because of the issues with Russia
Ukraine because of the fact we're
recovering from covert and we want to do
all we can to support households through
this difficult time whilst building a
better economy for the future which is
why investment is so important economic
growth is so important
how is it mischaracterization of what
she told me twice
well you'll appreciate Kay that I've
been working on the Foreign Affairs
brief on issues like the Northern
Ireland protocols I understand but
you're telling I didn't see the
interview okay well there you go how do
you know then how do you know it's
because authorization because I like the
interview because I know Rachel and I
know that she is somebody who cares
deeply about making sure that people are
able to get by that we deal with this
you know this issue of inflation that
we're facing in our economy and I think
you've mischaracterized what she said
well if you didn't hear what the the
interview or what was part of the
interview then there we are there were
two million views of it on uh my Twitter
feed uh Ed miliband uh trending on
Twitter yesterday as well after calling
Mishi sunak the dude from Silicon Valley
and the giant Ponzi scheme when he was
talking uh lightning his likening his
career to a giant Ponzi scheme in other
words saying that this this Government
is out of touch how would you respond
the chancellor is doing a fantastic job
in very difficult circumstances he
helped the country get through the covid
crisis we've got the lowest unemployment
since 1974. he's working very hard to
attract investment and you know if we
look at Ed miliband's record he was one
of the energy secretaries who failed to
invest in energy all those years ago
which is means that we are now playing
catch up in areas like nuclear energy
and renewable energy and these Richie
sunac is taking the right long-term
decisions for our country
you call the Northern Ireland protocol a
very grave and serious whereas the Prime
Minister he's saying that all we need is
minor tweaks which one's correct
we need sensible pragmatic changes to
the Northern Ireland protocol to make it
work for the people of Northern Ireland
but the reality is it isn't working on
the ground it has created political
instability in Northern Ireland we
haven't seen the executive form since
February so we do need to make these
changes and these changes will be make
it better for everyone they'll reduce
the bureaucracy on East-West trade
they'll mean that the people of Northern
Ireland are able to access the support
like the vat Cuts we've brought in in
Great Britain and it will also mean that
people are able to get all of the goods
in Northern Ireland that are available
to the people of Great Britain
minor tweaks or grave concern which one
is it
well this situation in Northern Ireland
is of grave concern the Belfast Good
Friday agreement was a huge step change
for Northern Ireland in a positive
direction we're now seeing that
undermined by the fact that the Northern
Ireland protocol isn't working and
that's why we need to make changes to
the Northern Ireland protocol so the
situation of grave concern is the
situation in the Northern Ireland
political system which we need to fix
through these changes to the Northern
Ireland protocol
I know those tweaks minor or major
we're not changing everything in the
protocol through our legislation we are
protecting the north-south relationship
we're protecting the single electricity
Market but there are some very serious
problems about East-West trade which we
need to fix we've proposed a solution
sharing commercial data having proper
enforcement so creating a Green Lane
into Northern Ireland that helps protect
the EU single Market which is what
they're concerned of and also helps
protect trade into Northern Ireland so
we can get a pragmatic solution I want
the EU to come to the negotiating table
so we can agree that together but if
that doesn't happen we do need to move
ahead delivering this solution for the
people of Northern Ireland
okay okay
um I think it's fair to say foreign
secretary and it's not of your own
making but um the government has angered
the dup the government has angered the
EU so where does that actually leave us
the UK are we sort of somewhere adrift
in the Irish sea
we have put forward a solution that base
delivers for the people of Northern
Ireland that delivers for uh the
problems that they've been facing
whether it's about tax or whether it's
about trade but also delivers for the EU
single market and that's what we want to
legislate for it's not scrapping the
protocol as some people have claimed
it's fixing the protocol making it
better make it work better and that
works for everybody that's the solution
we want to get to
um I just want to ask you a question on
behalf of Louise who runs the brick here
she's the chief executive of uh
basically a Lifeline for many people
here in Wigan and she wants to know
what's going to happen people are going
back to work other people can no longer
come here to be a volunteer what's the
government going to do to try to help
organizations like this with volunteers
so that this Lifeline for so many people
in Wigan can continue to be up and
running
well first of all can I thank Louise and
her team for the fantastic job they're
doing food banks offer a real support
for for people and we do want to make
sure that they have enough
volunteers one of the uh one of the
issues we're facing of course is because
of the very high levels of employment
the fact that more people are in work
sometimes it can be difficult to get
volunteer support but I would encourage
people to help out with their local food
bank to get involved and I very much
support the work she's doing
okay just a thought before I let you go
uh foreign secretary you are a very
strong very successful politician and
woman as well of course how did you feel
yesterday when you heard that an NP had
uh been arrested for rape
well I'm very very concerned about the
reports that I've heard clearly this is
a matter for the police the police are
currently working on the case but you
know it is worrying uh that we are
seeing uh
these are pulling these are pulling uh
accusations
again about a parliamentarian
do you feel that they should have been
suspended or had the whip withdrawal of
course were innocent until proven guilty
but someone's been arrested for rape is
it right that they still have the whip
at this stage
I think it's a matter for the police
about whether that individual is named I
don't know who it is I know that the
police are looking at it and
investigating it and I think we need to
wait for the police to conduct those
investigations I understand that this
individual is not on the Parliamentary
estate but I think we need to allow the
police to take those investigations
forward
understood but you are content for them
to keep the whip for now
well as I've said I don't know who they
are and I know the police are looking at
this case on a urgent basis
so you do feel it's content for them to
keep the whip for now
well I think it's a matter for the
police and it's a matter for law
enforcement and of course there's a
question about whether or not the name
is released at this well it's a it's a
question for no it's not a police about
whether it's kept or not there is that
no but if if the whip well if there was
a disclosure about the name of this
individual there could be an impact on
the victim and that is a matter for the
police
okay good to talk to you foreign
this morning very much appreciated thank
you
Louise is with us now hi Louise you
heard the response there from the uh
foreign secretary what do you think
um I think that it was just kind of a
wish wash of an answer really and not
really giving us anything that we can
actually focus on as you know volunteers
are the backbone of every charity and we
often pick up the slack which has been
left behind by budget cuts and
everything and if we don't have those
volunteers you know we're going to
suffer as well and our services are
going to suffer which means the people
good point though doesn't she Louise
that you know you have fewer volunteers
because more people are going back to
work there's a reasonable point it is
but we're talking about people who are
already semi-retired or retired that are
going back into the workforce
um and they're having to do that because
of the economic crisis and they can't
afford to live on just their pensions
alone so where somebody thought they
were going to like volunteer their time
as they retire they're now having to go
back to work and obviously we're losing
vital experience within the charity
because of that I know that you are
going to indulge Us by allowing us to
wander around all morning we really
appreciate that but for now thanks very
much Louise thanks a lot thank you let's
take you through where we are going to
be should we fall the last couple of
days of our time here in Wigan this
morning we're here at the brick which is
a local food bank providing for those
who are struggling the most with Rising
food prices not just food banks all
sorts of other stuff goes on as well
here as uh NZ is going to be just a few
miles down the road he's at Lee market
for us this morning then tomorrow
morning we'll be at Wigan Warriors yay
Rugby Club at Robin Park and insy will
be at a family-run bakery taking a look
God we're told by what is
hello
can you see the donkeys we didn't grow
up very well off and I was very aware
growing up that we didn't have a lot
they always didn't want my children to
feel that I never wanted them to do if I
never wanted them to
feel embarrassed because they're closed
they were wearing and stuff so that's I
guess that's what motivates me I can't
let them down got Rings swinging into
his Daisy
Nick Priestly has poured everything into
his own gym company
it just made it through covered
lockdowns he doesn't know if it'll
survive what's coming next
just as you're thinking oh finally start
actually getting a wage maybe have some
holidays maybe have some time off maybe
work a reasonable amount of hours rather
than doing 70 80 hours a week
you think you're on gonna have to you
know just just to pay the bills and
we're a pretty humble little family you
know we have a nice little terraced
house we we don't live beyond our Mains
we don't go out very much I don't really
drink yeah we live a pretty chilled out
life and even we're like what we call
back on here
in truth there's not much Nick's already
scaled back his gym business and
retrained in sports Rehabilitation
there's a huge pressure to make this
work and like many who are self-employed
he feels it's all on him
just make
all right so
I've not really got anyone behind me you
know this all goes wrong I I haven't
really got anyone to go to I'm doing
everything I can and even I'm like what
else can I do
there's nothing you can do when your
food bills are just climbing and
climbing and climbing and your house
bills are climbing and climbing and
climbing how much more can you cut back
and watch more and what more work can
you do
the Wiggins small businesses Rising
bills are crippling after two already
incredibly difficult years if we see
prices rocket again you know come
October
um there's a real danger that for many
firms they're gonna just go under you
know this this could actually be the
energy energy shock we're going to get
could be a bigger shock for for small
businesses than the actual pandemic
and it's not just profits that suffer of
course it's people it's families and
futures
Catherine evertotsi Sky News in Wigan
well as I said the brick is not just
about a food they do all sorts of things
and you'll find out more about it
throughout the course of the morning
this is one of the areas where bikes are
donated and then Tony Paul and Simon
good morning guys uh they renovate
refurbish these bikes and then they sell
them at very low cost that's really
important here to the people of Wigan
because of the cost of traveling around
transport even if you do have a job it's
quite difficult to make ends meet when
it comes to using buses Etc here these
are the white goods so these are again
donated and then they go from about 30
pounds upwards really important again
for people who are struggling on a
budget they need to be able to try and
keep the food fresh as they get it from
here at the Hub over here this is where
all the items come in and they are
sorted clothing household goods whatever
it might be there's a bed that's just
come in over there and then again people
can come here no judgment at all and at
very low cost they can purchase things
things like this sideboard not sure how
they get it home but we find that out in
the fullness of time again more items at
the back the household goods really that
people can't afford to go into a shop
and buy and then this way people can pop
in between nine and five five days a
week that reminds me of a ghetto blaster
when I was a little girl
that's another story nine to five people
can pop in here and get something
something to eat something warm to eat
watch this as you come past the Adam at
again very low cost one of the workers
here is Kevin Hey Kevin how are you it's
nice to see you that's a nice smile for
a thing in the morning now tell me what
you do here basically uh
volunteer and I build bikes
with Simon with Simon yeah
Dr by where we go to schools fix all
children's bikes so they can get back on
the road and do how important are bags
to people here in Wigan well it's it's
actually getting more important yeah
because field prices are going up yeah
so it's
and it's not Cheap on the bus no it's
not it's not cheaply anywhere before
struggling people to fall to live and am
I right in saying that there is a bike
route in Wigan so people can use they've
just finished the bike route the green
lens so if you when you're traveling
into Wigan yeah you'd see them yeah now
can we talk about
um the fact that you is it okay no no
yes yeah so um you used to have an
addiction didn't you yeah I used to have
the struggle with an addiction and a bad
pass for the past 20 years yeah in and
out of prison
but I found it hard because you'd get
released from prison and did not sort
your Aussie night yeah yeah and the only
people was my friends was people who
committed crime people who took drugs so
I got back into the same thing how did
you finally manage to break that Circle
because uh I ended up going into the air
Ben the the project what Andy Burnham's
created Andy Burnham's the greater
Manchester yeah gone into the and then
give me a replacement in the hotel
then heard about the scheme the brick
which would take it on volunteers which
is here where I am now and uh I started
volunteering and then I realized that I
can change my life around so I've been
here ever since I started retail with a
lady called Jen and I'm still here
living my life laugh for luxura happy as
Larry
how do you feel now as opposed to
Wellness commit well feeling no I'm
absolutely happy as anything but I come
I did me addiction but then I struggled
with my mental health yeah
because that's what another part of once
you've you're covering addiction you're
covering something up
and realizing that because I had this
place and I had new friends to talk to
who didn't got plenty of new friends
here
never going back to that because my goal
is now to try and teach these younger
ones that there's more to life
don't try and not make mistakes because
once you've made the mistake I know you
can people learn from some of them but
there's mistakes and there's mistakes do
you know what I mean think of your
future whilst you're young because what
is the future hold for you well I've not
it's the world's me oyster yeah I like
that I like that I can see that so you
keep that smile
shut your hand yeah you're welcome thank
you thank you thank you thanks for
talking about on the show this morning
thanks a lot yeah a little round of
applause I think
is amazing he's amazing thank you Kevin
thanks a lot nz's at Lee market for us
this morning Lindsay good morning
good morning Kay what an inspirational
story there um from Kevin welcome to Lee
Market just down the road from you still
won by Wigan Council we're here this
morning because of those shocking
inflation figures that have come out
this morning a 40-year high and prices
going up incredibly quickly that has a
huge knock-on effect to people right
across this region but of course across
the country and people like Catherine at
Cafe Central here
um we'll get your order in a sec okay
but Catherine first I want to find out
from you
um the impact of the cost of living
crisis and hearing this morning that
inflation is is at a record high
just okay what's the worst it's
completely naughty nightmare
everything's gone up
um just for instance in the oil is a big
price at the moment it's gone up like
near enough double in
in money and fish that's nearly doubled
in money you dry products for making
your batter just everything's
everything's just gonna open it's just a
complete nightmare at the minute and
you've been here for 16 years you've
pumped so much money into this place of
just a little kitchen behind us where
you started off initially and then
you've expanded to this uh amazing place
now but you've got stuff to think about
as well so all those finances how much
of a worry is that looking to the future
with the cost of living prices the
concert we're at every single day is a
concert where it's I'm imagined all the
time I'm thinking they have to lay a
staff off which is not something I don't
want to do but and it did I need to keep
the business going as long as I can but
every day is a worry and you just put
prices up on Monday only on Monday we
put the prices up which it had to do
because otherwise I'm going to close
down I'd say every every day is a
struggle I'm penny pinching from one day
to Annex every single day and just
finally the impact of the pandemic and
now the war in Ukraine as a result and
the cost of living crisis it was a
double whammy for you wasn't it it was
because we had to pause Jane for uh for
Corvette
at which yes we went out but
it didn't bring our customers back and
you know this not being able to come
back because a lot of them are elderly
and they have to get taxes into town
um so the cat for taxes tax Affairs are
going up bus fares have gone up it's
just a nightmare reel it's just a shame
for those customers as well because they
can't afford to come out I know it's
we're not a very expensive Cafe but
every little codes to them as well where
they used to be able to come out and
have a chat and a brew no they can't
Catherine thank you we came in and saw
yesterday afternoon it was quite busy
here so you've got a loyal a lot of
loyal customers and hoping that you know
your amazing food keeps you going I
think for the months and years ahead
what's your specialty quickly fish and
chips fish and chips I can't have that
at 7 30 in the morning you can have an
omelette though okay maybe we'll see an
omelette perhaps but we'll be speaking
to more Traders like Catherine some
customers a bit later on but clearly a
worry for a lot of people across Wigan
and here in Lee about the inflation and
the prices rising so quickly okay
Lindsay you can have fish and chips at
any time of day don't be ridiculous a
bit of mushy Peas on the side as well
[Laughter]
thanks a lot coming up we're going to be
speaking uh to the manager of the uh
Community grocery store here in Wigan
helping struggling families with their
food shop
boxing for better we'll speak to the
founder of a local boxing club helping
to get children off the streets and into
the gym
and after eight I'll be joined by the
shadow Chancellor Rachel Reeves
before that though let's bring you some
of the morning's other news for you here
on the program and a conservative MP has
been arrested on suspicion of rape and
sexual assault over a seven year period
Scotland Yard says officers are
questioning a man in his 50s who remains
in custody let's get more should we
Manny Radcliffe is standing by for us
outside New Scotland Yard hello to you
Maddie tell us more
thank you Kay well we can now say that
the MP in his 50s has been released on
bail having spent the night in custody
we don't know his name that's normal
protocol the Metropolitan Police don't
name suspects until they have been
charged but the conservative party have
also decided not to name the MP they say
they don't want to jeopardize the
victim's anonymity or haven't and they
also haven't taken a decision on his
future whether to expel him from the
party until the investigation is
concluded and as you put till his trust
earlier there will be questions over
their handling of this because this
comes amid huge a huge recent string of
allegations and Scandals within
Westminster about behavior of MPS the
bigger picture to this is 56 MPS
according to the Sunday Times have been
investigated for some form of sexual
misconduct that's nearly one in ten we
know that in just the last year 15 have
been investigated by the Parliamentary
Watchdog which specializes in bullying
and sexual assault claims just recently
uh ran Khan was convicted of sexually
assaulting a boy Neil Tiverton has
stepped down after admitting watching
porn in the House of Commons David
Warburton has had the whip removed after
allegations of sexual assault and Drug
taking it's not just the conservative
party but this will come at it comes at
a very bad time for the reputation of
Parliament and will certainly increase
scrutiny over how to protect people
working in Parliament and enforce
standards at the moment obviously the MP
hasn't been named he hasn't had the whip
removed and he still could go into
Poland Parliament although the chief
whip has asked him to stay away
okay for no thanks Maddie thank you in
other news President zielinski says
Ukraine is still working to extract its
last remaining troops from the as of
style steel plant in mariopol more than
250 Ukrainian soldiers have been
evacuated they had resisted the Russian
advance for many weeks in Desperate
circumstances joining us now is Dominic
he's standing by for us in Ukraine car
cave to be precise so we had thought
that potentially all of the military
were out but some of them still remain
Dom tell us more
yeah we did we heard from their
relatives and we k um who were
expressing relief teams with some
anxiety and I think the picture for them
and their husbands and Sons is darkening
there are reports and rumors causing
mounting concern uh for them all into
all we know in terms of facts is that uh
what we knew yesterday which is more
than 260 have been evacuated uh around
50 of them to a hospital and the rest to
another town in the russian-held uh east
of Ukraine now the ukrainians say that
they've been released and extracted as
part of a prisoner exchange scheme
negotiated with the Russians the
Russians say that they have surrendered
the kremen says Vladimir Putin is
guaranteeing they'll be treated under
International standards but there are
negotiators officials and politicians in
Moscow on the Russian side saying some
of them should be put on trial and face
the death penalty even though there is a
moratorium on uh death penalties in
Russia the reason for that they say is
there are amongst these men members of
the azov Battalion that they regard as a
Neo-Nazi unit and it's hard to see them
Russians resisting the temptation to put
on trial some of them want to kind of
televise show trial even though we've
had criminal assurances that they will
be treated under International standards
so concerns about those who've been
evacuated and we still don't know how
many are still stuck in the as as of
style still works um who now face the
Dilemma of being told to lay down their
arms not to fight anymore by their
commanders but hearing the same reports
and rumors as we are presumably worried
about their fate if they leave the still
works so very difficult for them and for
their wives and mothers waiting for more
news this morning
okay thank you thanks a lot also making
news for you police in Nottingham have
arrested a man after Sheffield United
Striker Billy sharp was head-butted on
the pitch Following last night's playoff
semi-final Nottingham Forest secured
their first trip to Wembley in more than
30 years after beating Sheffield United
on penalties at the city ground
Wayne Rooney has told the high court
that he was asked by the fa to speak to
teammate Jamie vardy about his wife
Rebecca's Behavior back in 2016. the
former England Captain was giving
evidence yesterday in a libel trial
brought by Mrs vardy against Rooney's
wife Colleen Jamie vardy described Wayne
Rooney's claims as nonsense
everybody
new findings suggest pollution was
responsible for nine million deaths
around the globe in 2019. the data
published in the medical journal the
Lancet says chemical and water pollution
accounted for one in six deaths
worldwide
North Korea has reported that more than
232 000 people have symptoms of covid
the country's leader Kim Jong-un accused
Health officials of immaturity and
slackness in the way that they have
handled the outbreak
Charles and Camilla on a royal tour of
Canada marking the Queen's Platinum
Jubilee on a visit to Saint John's in
Newfoundland yesterday the royal couple
paid their respects to thousands of
indigenous children who were abused in
residential schools bringing a message
of healing and understanding but no
formal apology
short while ago the foreign secretary
Liz trust told me the UK is facing the
very difficult economic situation after
inflation hit a 40-year high of 9 in
April
we are in a very very difficult economic
situation we're facing some very very
serious Global headwinds and you know as
you've said inflation is extremely high
what we're doing is working to increase
growth in our economy attract investment
to the United Kingdom to face down these
Global headwinds but there's no doubt it
is very difficult for people across
Britain and in fact across the world
hi ali um it's with us this morning
thoughts on that morning yeah I think it
was interesting because obviously the
government under under a huge amount of
pressure now to find something to help
people with the cost of living we heard
Liz trust there um I think suggesting
that from her perspective the windfall
tax isn't a great idea even though we
have heard the government tone on that
changing over the last few weeks we've
seen the chancellor and the Prime
Minister basically saying it hasn't been
ruled out she made clear I think that
what she wants is taxes to calm down she
said lower taxes are the best way some
reports this morning that we could see
the income tax cut being moved forward
to the Autumn that is not something that
the treasury are confirming though so
which direction the government will go
in we don't know yet but clearly there's
a huge amount of pressure we've been
hearing from the people here today okay
lovely thanks so much indeed for now
thanks a lot right heading in this
General Direction Come with Me Adam if
you would looking for Liz Wesley's hand
up Liz Liz Liz Liz Liz Liz is where
there she oh there she is
too busy chatting Liz a bit like me how
are you this morning lovely to see you
thanks for is that somebody else's tea
it's mine now anyway
and now your manager at Sunshine House
Community Center aren't you yes I am
okay tell me about your work
um our community center is we have
oh you're a bit nervous I am why are you
nervous it's just me and you I know um
so we have a cafe where people come in
from around schools and music plant
Three Corner where I wrote rooms to
different organizations like the council
NHS things like that okay okay how does
it help the local community do you think
and we have social groups and like new
friends and new beginnings things like
we have AAA and
cocaine addiction things like that okay
um do you think that we're seeing the
inflation figures at nine percent today
yes do you think the government's doing
enough to help people who come to your
Center no what do you want them to do
um I want obviously
it's about money yeah but it's about
more than money I'm guessing of course
it is yeah because we're quite worried
about these index where people are
taking Longs out to cover the long what
we got previous yeah and when we talk
about hidden debt what we're talking
about there is the fact that you know
we're a pro bunch and we can aren't we
yeah and we we would rather take out
um some sort of loan or whatever in
order rather than ask for help yes and
because we are a pro Bunch we can people
I think on the children came to life
better than what they are yeah growing
up and how have you found
um the rising cost of living impacting
on what you're doing
um a lot really
um our charity shops have actually been
used so much more we've got three times
what you sell we've got a clothes shop a
baby and toddler shop and
um a toy shop so yeah being used a lot
more okay I don't know if Adam can have
a look around here while I'm still
chatting to you and just show our
viewers back home some of the things
that people can actually buy here is
this the sort of thing that you do as
well yes we do
um we are actually building
relationships with the brick right and
showing resources and have you found
that more and more people are coming to
you what sort of people how would you
describe the people for the People for
People at home who are watching how
would you describe that
um people like families young families
and well all ages really yeah we are
providing like a lot more
you know from the charity shop yeah yeah
what's your message to those people who
in Wigan who'll be watching you this
morning who are struggling and thinking
I'm just too embarrassed I can't I can't
go to a center like that I can't go and
ask for help people come to Sunshine ice
and brick and use our resources and they
get a warm welcome to do a cup of tea
yes bacon butter a bacon
didn't mention the bacon butter did you
it's lovely to see you see it wasn't
that bad was it it's only the ministers
I give a hard time
actually who knows Uncle Joe's meatballs
I mean who doesn't right who doesn't we
went there yesterday they've been
struggling as well actually over the
last couple of years but um things are
on the up and they're going to start
selling them in New York
so here's our report
so I thought I'd bring my Southern wing
woman uh to Uncle Joe's mid-ball Factory
today if you pass through Wigan on the
train you'll see this great big sign
behind us but for me it means something
very different it's been here since 1898
so enjoyed by many generations what are
your memories of it Kay well amongst
other things the very well-known song If
you're from Wigan you know there's a
song about Uncle Joe's meatballs and
you'll know what happens if you give one
to your granny but what about if you
give one to your wing woman do you want
to try it does it have a bit of a kick
yep let's see there's a place in Wigan a
place you all should know a fizzy little
Factory where things are all the gold
they don't make jigsaw Eccles cakes off
things do stick on walls but night and
day they work away at Uncle Joseline
Falls Stars
[Music]
John we've met a few times how's
business
been very difficult very challenging the
last two years but it looks like a bit
of chance of getting better now in what
way we don't say show in New York in
three weeks time we're getting our
meatballs all over the world yeah we've
got to Australia New Zealand and there's
lots of exciting things ahead okay tell
me just a little bit about Uncle Joe's
meatballs and why they're so important
to the town of winter we've been here
since 1898. it was my great great uncle
who started the company so we're still
very much a family business we've
employed many people over the years I
would like to take people to an iconic
part of Wigan along with the football
and the rugby yeah and things are
picking up as you were saying things are
picking up and I can see a bit of Hope
on the horizon fantastic thank you
fresh off the line yeah what did you say
delicious when things are all the gold
they don't make jigsaw Eccles kicks off
things still stick on walls
so Uncle Joe's mint balls it was and
she's a convert now oh tomorrow she
loves those sweeties so this is just to
illustrate for you at home this is just
some of the stuff that comes in from the
good people of Wigan who are donating
Lomo here obviously
um
you know it'll all have to get sorted
out and then they'll put it in the
relevant area and then people will come
in maybe they need um some clothing
um that again puts gets put into a
relative area over there Adam as we can
see and if you're in need you can come
in obviously difficult time for parents
as well with young children that will be
very very useful for someone obviously
somebody who's donated it no need for it
anymore but will be incredibly useful
for a young family who need to keep
their kids occupied come this way if you
would because I want to introduce you to
Alex Burton Alex is a community uh
grocery manager and she is here now hire
how are you thanks for taking the time
to join us this morning tell me about
the community Grocery and how that works
yeah so the community grocery in Wigan
is a partnership between today's
Community Church and the message trust
which is a charity in Manchester and the
currently 15 Community groceries across
the country and three more open in the
coming months as well and but in terms
of how we work we have a five pound
membership and that lasts for a year and
then it's four pounds each time someone
comes to shop and they can get about 20
items for that which is a mixture of
fruit and veg and shelf items and Frozen
item and and on average it's about 15 to
20 pounds saving Perth shop so they
basically join the club and then they
pay for parents and it could be 20 quids
worth of food that they get for that
time of it
um how do you manage to uh where do you
get the funds from to to make that work
yeah because I can't see the math there
and this year this is really um we have
a lot of support from the public and and
then also we partner with
um Food suppliers and and get stuck
through that and also collect from
supermarkets as well so you get you I
used to work at a food bank in Harrow
where I live now and they um got a lot
of stuff from supermarkets that would
have been landfill otherwise so is that
what you do yeah definitely so we have a
van that goes around in the week and
collects from lots of different
supermarkets and what about your
volunteers how are you coping there and
yeah so we have a good team of
volunteers and I say we're partnership
with the church we have volunteers from
there and also members of the public who
come in throughout the week and are you
finding it difficult to to get
volunteers as people go back to work and
the like yeah and I think definitely
when we went through a season of that at
the end of furlough and but we've been
building back up since then yeah okay
and
how many people would you say are
benefiting from the work that you do
yeah and so in our grocery in Wigan we
have 1 500 members and then across the
network of groceries we have about 20
000 members and families that we're
supporting okay and the sort of people
that come along and yeah so it's a real
mix but I think particularly since the
start of the year we've seen an increase
in members but um I'd say an increase in
number of people who maybe six months
ago wouldn't have been and find
themselves in a place of financial
insecurity but with the rise in cost of
living and Rising bills that's
definitely a conversation that will
happen with people more recently and
that are finding themselves in a
position where they're needing support
inside the grocery amazing amazing work
that you do thank you so much for
sharing that with us we really
appreciate it thank you well let me tell
you that for many people sport is
released from the stress and pressures
of life it's also a way of getting
children off the streets and giving them
a sense of purpose um David Morris hey
David today no I'll come to you don't
you worry David is a founder of boxing
of For Better hire nice to see you tell
me about the work you do
um so in boxing for boxing for better we
offer free boxing sessions for children
and young people in Wigan and Lee
um so it's for age 9 16 and it's just
something fun to do regular a nice
positive activities that they can do to
try and hopefully keep them out of
trouble keeping away from social
behavior and just give them something
where they can mix other people and just
enjoy them ourselves with no barriers
and do you find that it's difficult to
get kids to come along to start with
they're a bit of a challenge because
some of them can be of course and to be
honest we tried to count that so that
our model we don't have a boxing gym we
offer like a satellite Club so we go to
communities what we've identified as
being perhaps disadvantaged or they
might have more people that Define
poverty are for your school meals so we
take the sessions out so we take all our
goals down there our cultures go down
then we run it in the in the natural
Community where they live so they don't
have to go anywhere so we're trying to
reduce as many barriers as possible what
do you do with those that want to be a
bit disruptive we get a lot of them but
that's the idea of course I think boxing
is quite a good tool for those sorts of
children
um there's like a rugged nature to
boxing and
just the the nature of the training that
we're doing the way that we deliver it
and the way that our co-ops engage with
young people we tend to turn around
we've had quite a few success stories
with some children that have come in and
not really knowing how to be part of
that group and not really know how to
work within a team and listen to
cultures and take directions and we're
seeing now that along with this spent
with us the more able they are to do
that and hopefully that translates into
school and at home and what about
um kit and stuff like that so we have to
provide it all the children come down
they don't pay for it all they need is
sports Claws and a water bottle we
provide nothing else but that's where
our funding comes in so we're obviously
lucky to have one or two sponsors and we
do what could grant funding but that's
limited there's only so much out there
and then it's just good will of other
people people that can offer donations
or sponsors or just provide some of that
funding so we can continue the service
that we offer and how many kids do you
think you're helping at the moment so we
started 12 months ago it started on the
back end of restrictions being lifted
and I think we've delivered 1 600 free
sessions to engage 450 young people wow
that's amazing every week we have
because we have three sessions one in
Platt Bridge which is we're going one in
highball which is Lee and one in shackle
which is still
um and we have about 75 to 100 young
people attend those three sessions every
week right that's amazing amazing and
why did you come up with the idea it was
a little bit of a combination thing it's
something I've always wanted to do
because I used to be into boxing myself
and I've always wanted to use it as a
vehicle to make social change rather
than just to make good boxes and then I
think there's a bit of a perfect storm
the restrictions are being lifted my
boxing club was a victim of the pandemic
that shut down so I just had a bit of
time in the hand there was an
opportunity where people need to go out
doing things again and we just decided
that was going to start it and it
started just a six-week pilot program
was going to deliver it in higher folds
I was going to do it with my equipment
that I already had and it's just
snowballed from the people I think we've
got any famous boxers from work and have
we I can't think of any off the top of
my head so we had Craig Lyon and John
bonded really well John is probably one
of our most successful Olympic boxers
and then we've got a few that have come
you know from other Marty Murray's
training Lee but he's at a training wig
and sorry but he's from centellings but
he's on a lot in this area so we've got
one or two that have done well amazing
good to talk to you thanks very much
indeed we're just going to squeeze past
you though that's all right let's go
this way Adam should we because I want
to talk to um Pat thanks a lot thanks a
lot it's Pat around hi hello love how
are you I'm all right tell me about
volunteering here
um well I work in the kitchen and I'm a
mentor for the volunteers and the
trainees and the trainees are like
moving on from and they're getting ready
for their own place so they're coming
here and we cook meals from food from
the food bank or what's going to waste
but we can use
and then they can get some sort of idea
on making their own meals when they get
to their own place so what did you think
of that Tory MP the other daily Anderson
who was saying that the people have a
problem because they don't know how to
cook did he have a point
um I think they've all been brought up
well not everybody but they've been
brought up with the takeaways and things
and they don't sort of get educated with
the basic ingredients to make nutritious
and economical meals but yeah it can be
done yeah and that's what the people are
learning here yeah yeah tell me
something that you know what what sort
of raw ingredients would you have and
what you'd be able to knock up from that
right well we always have potatoes and
we always have tins of coffee I know you
say potatoes Posh because you're on the
tennis yeah there we go potatoes and
corned beef yeah and then we can make
like
five yeah yeah
um we get sausages donated sometimes but
we can take the skins off to make
burgers very good and it's a sausage pie
with the mash on the top put the packing
in with the onions and other things
and what you're cooking today uh well
we've done breakfast
oh that's good
that's fantastic and what's for lunch
um well basically because we're doing
this here yeah and I'm just providing
bacon and sausage sandwiches for
everyone exactly what's your favorite
dish
um I don't know I just like anything you
don't want to make all sorts of things
and it depends on what's been given to
us yeah that we try to combine and uh
make a good meal and we serve about 25
30 people a day wow but it's everybody
who works here the mentors and the
volunteers yeah so they all get a good
meal and I'm glad to hear it and if
there's anything left they can take it
off
thanks very much I'll see you a bit
later thanks so
thanks a lot thanks everybody we're
going to come and chat with you again a
bit later on ladies and gents if I'm
here we're going to be here at the brick
all morning actually this reminds me
like just a look here and this reminds
me of my early days
yeah can you see how hard it is to type
no my god when you when you um use a
laptop you just have to push really hard
to get those keys to work I used to use
an olivetti when I worked at my local
paper here and we're gonna go in that
way Adam if you don't mind uh talking
about the cost of living we've had the
latest inflation figures up to nine
percent we also heard from the foreign
secretary who was suggesting to me that
she couldn't rule out the possibility
that we may be facing a recession later
in the year talked about Northern
Ireland as well the protocol but what
really matters to the people here at the
brick this morning is how are they many
people here in my hometown how are they
coping from week to week to week places
like this help them but for how much
longer stay tuned for more live from
Wigan
[Music]